When you save an entity with a key, it creates a new
entity in the data store with that key. As you found out
earlier, this creates a key conflict. If an entity with that key
already exists, it is out of luck and it gets chucked out.
It's overwritten in the data store. So if you want to update
an existing entity, first you need to get it out of the
data store, then you make your updates and then you save it
back into the data store again. So back here in the save profile
method of that conference API, whenever we've been saving our
profile the first thing we do is create a new
profile with the user ID. That means that actually every
time you update your profile, you're not really updating it,
you'll create a new profile entity which overrides the existing
profile entity. You can see how that plays out in
the API Explorer. Now that we've implemented get profile, we
can just call get profile to get the existing profile
for the current user. So let's do that. Okay. let's see, so my display name
is "Chocolate Cake" and my t-shirt size is XL. Now, let's say I want to
change that, I want to change my t-shirt size, so I go to
saveProfile and the only thing I want to do is to change my
t-shirt size from XL to XS, extra small, this time.
Now we'll execute. And what would be really nice,
would be that the only thing that changes it
the t-shirt size. So let's see if it will
happen. But, no, that's not what happens. You see
how the display name gets set back to the
default, which is example and my t-shirt size did
change. What should really happen, the saveProfile method should
get the existing profile and only update the fields that
have changed. So that's going to be your next task.